No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没有人会为了汉克的电子表格而去Hank's餐厅，他们是冲着美味的披萨去的。不过最近店里有点冷清。于是汉克决定推出1美元切片披萨。他请Microsoft Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，帮他算算这是否划算。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小物件能让1美元披萨的薄利多销行得通。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. It's a cliche that you only get one chance to make a first impression, but it turns out that science bears this out. First impressions matter, and they're often surprisingly accurate. From the moment you meet someone, at a party, a job interview, or even just crossing paths at the grocery store, your brain is quickly summing them up. Whether you mean to do it or not, you're assigning
现在，汉克店门外排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。访问 M365Copilot.com/work 了解更多。俗话说，只有一次机会给人留下第一印象，但科学证明确实如此。第一印象很重要，而且往往出奇地准确。从你与人相遇的那一刻起，无论是在派对上、求职面试中，还是仅仅在杂货店擦肩而过，你的大脑都在迅速地评估他们。无论你是有意还是无意，你都在给
people to social categories and making judgments about their personality and other qualities. But exactly how accurate are our first impressions? What kinds of information can we glean about someone in the first moments of meeting them or even from just a photograph? Can you tell whether someone is extroverted, trustworthy, a good leader, gay or lesbian? What about their political leanings or whether they grew up wealthy? To what degree are our first impressions based on something real and to what extent are they based on stereotypes or biases? And what are the real world consequences of our accurate and inaccurate snap judgments? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links
人们归入社会类别，并对他们的性格和其他品质做出判断。但是我们的第一印象到底有多准确？在与某人相遇的最初几刻，甚至仅仅从一张照片中，我们能收集到关于对方的什么信息？你能看出一个人是外向的、值得信赖的、是个好的领导者，还是同性恋？他们的政治倾向如何？或者他们是否出身富裕？我们的第一印象在多大程度上基于真实的东西，又在多大程度上基于刻板印象或偏见？我们准确和不准确的瞬间判断会带来哪些现实后果？欢迎收看《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨
between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Nicholas Rule, a professor of psychology and vice provost for academic programs at the University of Toronto. His research focuses on the science of snap judgments and first impressions. He studies how we perceive other people when we first meet them, when we're accurate and when we're not, and the consequences of those quick judgments. Dr. Ruhl has published hundreds of academic papers, and his research has been covered widely in the mainstream media, including by CNN, the New York Times, NPR, and the Washington Post. He is also editor-in-chief of the Journal of Experimental Social Psychology and was recently elected,
心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是多伦多大学心理学教授兼学术项目副教务长尼古拉斯·鲁尔博士。他的研究重点是瞬间判断和第一印象的科学。他研究我们初次相遇时如何感知他人、何时准确何时不准确，以及这些快速判断的后果。鲁尔博士已发表了数百篇学术论文，他的研究被主流媒体广泛报道，包括CNN、纽约时代、NPR和《华盛顿邮报》。他还是《实验社会心理学杂志》的主编，最近当选为
the 27 president of the Society for Personality and Social Psychology. Dr. Ruhl, thank you for joining me. It's my great pleasure to be here, Kim. So when we first meet someone, how quickly do we start to make judgments and form an impression of them? Does it happen within seconds, milliseconds, and what kinds of judgments are we making in that brief time? It happens instantly, actually, and long before you realize it. So that would be on the order of milliseconds, as you say. the types of judgments that we make about people, they can vary a bit, but generally they follow something that you could almost consider along the lines of a hierarchy of needs.
人格与社会心理学学会第二十七任会长。鲁尔博士，谢谢你接受我的采访。金，非常高兴能来到这里。那么，当我们第一次见到某人时，我们多快开始做出判断并形成对他们的印象？这发生在几秒钟、几毫秒内，我们在那短暂的时间里做出了什么样的判断？其实是瞬间发生的，远在你意识到之前。正如你所说，那将是在毫秒量级。我们对人们做出的判断类型，可能会有所不同，但总体而言，它们遵循着一种你几乎可以认为是类似于需求层次结构的东西。
And so the first thing that we'll size up about a person is whether they're going to be a danger to us. Is this someone that's going to hurt me? Is this someone who's going to help me? Are they safe or are they not? After that, the next type of judgment we tend to make is how useful they might be to me, and particularly around whether this is an opportunity, for me to mate with a person.
因此，我们对一个人进行评估的第一件事就是他们是否会对我们构成危险。这个人会伤害我吗？这个人会帮助我吗？他们是安全的还是不安全的？在那之后，我们倾向于做出的下一类判断是他们对我有多少用处，尤其是这是否是一个让我与某人繁衍后代的机会。
And so we make an assessment about their gender, their interest, their age, and other factors that might lead us to make a judgment about whether they are compatible with us in terms of fertility. After that, we proceed on to higher order questions. And so one might be a little bit more complicated, but a version of what I said in the first one, which is, is this person my ally? Can I affiliate with them? Or are they someone who belongs to a different group from me?
因此，我们对他们的性别、兴趣、年龄以及其他可能导致我们判断他们在生育能力方面是否与我们契合的因素进行评估。在此之后，我们进入更高层次的问题。其中一个可能会稍微复杂一点，但它是我在第一个问题中所述内容的某种变体，即这个人是我的盟友吗？我可以与他们结盟吗？还是他们属于与我不同的群体？
And that's slightly different than whether they're dangerous or not, though sometimes those things can be overlapping. Beyond that, we start to get into these really higher order kinds of things. And so some of the judgments that you mentioned, is this person extroverted? Is this person a good leader? And those are more social or human dimensions that go beyond sort of the judgments that we would make
这与他们是否危险略有不同，尽管有时这些情况会有所重叠。除此之外，我们开始进入这些真正更高层次的东西。因此，你提到的一些判断，这个人外向吗？这个人是个好领导吗？这些是更具社交性或人类特性的维度，超越了我们对动物、其他物体等所做的基本判断，
more basically about animals, other objects and things like that, from which our judgments of people are largely based. And all of this happens, as I said, extremely quickly within milliseconds before we even have an opportunity to really think about what's happening. And that's a critical piece of what transpires in our interactions with people later on, in other words, how we begin to treat them. Much of your research focuses on how well people can pick up on what you call perceptually ambiguous groups, things that you'd think wouldn't be obvious from
而我们对人的判断很大程度上正是基于这些。正如我所说，所有这一切都发生得极快，在几毫秒内，甚至在我们有机会真正思考发生的事情之前。这是我们后来与人交往中发生的事情的关键部分，换句话说，就是我们如何开始对待他们。你的很多研究都集中在人们对你所谓的感知模糊群体的捕捉能力上，比如你认为从
someone's appearance like political affiliation or religion, sexual orientation, social class, even I think you mentioned leadership success. Can you tell us about that work? How accurately are people able to pick up on these traits from a quick meeting or even just from a photo? Well, the short answer is about 65%. And so that's kind of the average overall. But that varies quite a bit, depending on what type of judgment you're making, how you're making the judgment. So accuracy for photos is a lot lower. That's on the lower end, right? We have less information there versus interacting with someone and live face-to-face.
一个人的外表看不出来的东西，如政治倾向或宗教信仰、性取向、社会阶层，甚至我想你提到过的领导成功。你能跟我们谈谈那项工作吗？人们能够从一次快速的会面甚至只是一张照片中准确地捕捉到这些特质吗？嗯，简短的回答大约是65%。所以这算是总体平均水平。但这会有相当大的变化，取决于你做出判断的类型、你如何做出判断。因此，照片的准确性要低得多。那是在较低端，对吧？与某人进行面对面的实时互动相比，我们在那里获得的信息更少。
You get so much more information than you would get in a two-dimensional photograph. Or even in the case of some of the studies we've run in my lab, where we're showing people really just parts of faces. So individual eyes. And yet we find that from just a pair of eyes, black and white photograph, no brow is visible that people can make judgments about things like their sexual orientation better than they would be able to do if they were just guessing. And so it's maybe a low bar to say that we're better than a 50-50 chance of guessing whether someone's gay or straight.
你获得的信息比在二维照片中获得的信息要多得多。甚至在我实验室进行的一些研究中，我们向人们展示的实际上只是脸部的部分。比如单独的眼睛。然而我们发现，仅从一幅黑白照片上的一对眼睛，看不到眉毛，人们就能对诸如性取向之类的事情做出判断，这比他们仅仅靠瞎猜要好。所以说我们猜测某人是同性恋还是异性恋的几率比50-50更好，这或许是一个较低的标准。
But systematically, over a period of judgments, that adds up to something that's pretty meaningful and gives us insight about the mind. and brain. And so, as I mentioned, it can depend a little bit on the type of judgment that you're making as well. So, for example, some judgments like judging someone's age is shockingly accurate. And so in studies that we've run in my lab, we find that people can judge another person's age within about three years. It's incredible accuracy. And if you sort of quantify that in a different way, people are accurate roughly 80% of the time in judging a person's relative age. Judgments of gender are much higher. They tend to be almost at ceiling, almost 100% accuracy.
但从系统性来看，经过一段时间的判断后，这累积起来就变得相当有意义，并让我们对思维和大脑有了深入的了解。正如我所提到的，它也可能在一定程度上取决于你所做的判断类型。因此，例如，一些判断，比如判断某人的年龄，准确性高得惊人。因此在我们实验室进行的研究中，我们发现人们可以在大约三岁以内判断另一个人的年龄。这是令人难以置信的准确性。如果你以另一种方式将其实际量化，人们在判断一个人的相对年龄时，准确率大约为80%左右。性别的判断要高得多。它们往往接近上限，几乎达到100%的准确率。
There are, of course, always exceptions to these things. And I think we can, when you think about the popular media, they often make light of things like this. So there was the famous Pat skit on Saturday Night Live, you know, decades ago, right? Which plays on some of these errors that people might make, or at least the ambiguity around it. So accuracy, as I say, can vary quite a bit. It really does depend on what kind of judgment you're making. And part of that, too, is sort of the opportunity that you have to make that judgment, right? As I said, whether it's from a visual perception, an auditory perception,
当然，这些事情总有例外。我想我们可以，当你想到大众媒体时，他们经常对这种事情开玩笑。所以几十年前周六夜现场有一个著名的帕特小品，对吧？它利用了人们可能犯的一些错误，或者至少是围绕它的模糊性。因此，正如我所说，准确性可能会有很大差异。这确实取决于你做出哪种判断。其中一部分原因也是你做出这种判断的机会，对吧？正如我所说，无论是从视觉感知还是听觉感知来看，
oftentimes auditory judgments are better than visual judgments, even though we as a visual species, you know, one quarter of our brain is devoted to just processing visual information, we tend to prioritize visual information about people, but oftentimes other senses actually pick up things a little bit more. And that's one of the more fascinating parts of this area of research. So what kinds of information or cues are we picking up on when we're making these judgments? And are we doing it consciously or is it all happening below our actual awareness? Well, it's a combination, right? And so, I mean, there are some judgments where obviously, if
往往听觉判断要好于视觉判断，尽管我们作为一种视觉动物，你知道，我们四分之一的大脑专门用于处理视觉信息，我们倾向于优先处理关于人们的视觉信息，但实际上往往其他感官能捕捉到更多一点的东西。这是这个研究领域最迷人的部分之一。那么，当我们做出这些判断时，我们正在捕捉什么样的信息或线索？我们是有意识地这样做，还是这一切都发生在我们的实际意识之下？嗯，这是一个组合，对吧？所以，我的意思是，有一些判断显然是，如果
if I ask you to judge whether somebody is, say, extroverted or introverted, you're going to be consciously thinking about it. However, it turns out that you probably already made a decision about that before I asked you. And so depending on the circumstances, it's usually a combination of the two. That said, we do have evidence from a variety of studies showing that a lot of this occurs outside of awareness. So as I said, you know, a few minutes ago, before you even start to think about what you're doing, your brain has largely done it. As I mentioned, some of the judgments that we make,
我要求你判断某人是外向还是内向，你会刻意去思考它。然而事实证明，在我问你之前，你可能已经对此做出了决定。因此，根据具体情况，它通常是两者的结合。话虽如此，我们从各种研究中得到证据表明，其中很大一部分发生在意识之外。所以正如我刚才所说，几分钟前，甚至在你开始思考自己在做什么之前，你的大脑就已经基本完成了。正如我所提到的，我们所做的一些判断，
they follow this sort of sequence. And at first we're sort of getting kind of the broad contours of a person. So their size, their proximity. From there, we go on to these sort of finer distinctions, such as things like, I just mentioned a moment ago, eyes, but I'll go to eyebrows. So the shape of someone's eyebrows is something that we make a judgment about and that influences the way that we interact with them.
它们遵循这种序列。起初，我们有点在获取一个人的大致轮廓。比如他们的体型、他们的距离。从那里，我们转向这些更精细的区分，比如我刚才提到的眼睛，但我会说到眉毛。因此，某人的眉毛形状是我们做出判断并影响我们与他们互动方式的一点。
So, for example, in a series of studies that we did a few years ago, we found that people could reliably judge whether someone was narcissistic from just looking at their eyebrows. And to your question about sort of what are we picking up on, in that case, it turns out that it was the grooming of the eyebrows. So people with more groomed eyebrows tended to have higher levels of grandiose narcissism. And people somehow know that. People pick up on that and they make an inference about it based on just that very, very tiny bit of inference. They then sort of run with that and kind of explode it in a way and make a lot more out of it than perhaps they sometimes should. How does snap judgments interact with stereotypes and bias? I understand that you found, for instance, that people perceive black men, and I assume this as white people, perceive black men as larger and more threatening than same size white men. So how much of our, quote, intuition about people is actually bias?
例如，在我们几年前做的一系列研究中，我们发现人们仅通过看一眼别人的眉毛，就能可靠地判断出对方是否自恋。对于你关于我们在捕捉什么的提问，在这种情况下，事实证明那是对眉毛的修饰。因此，眉毛修饰得更多的人往往具有更高水平的夸大自恋。人们不知何故知道了这一点。人们注意到了这一点，并仅凭那非常非常微小的推断做出了推断。然后他们顺着这个思路进行某种程度的夸大，从中解读出比有时应有的更多的东西。瞬间判断如何与刻板印象和偏见相互作用？据我了解，你发现，例如，人们认为黑黑人男性（我假设这是指白人）比同等体型的白人男性更大、更具威胁性。那么，我们对人的所谓“直觉”实际上有多少是偏见？
I'm so glad that you asked that because that's such an important part of this whole process of perceiving people. And the answer is quite a lot is bias, actually. A lot of that bias comes from patterns based on our own idiosyncratic experiences, including things that we've observed and a lot of it from things that other people have told us. And we're kind of sponges for information about other people, in ways that lead to making assessments of whether someone is going to be safe for us or not. And so generally in psychology,
我很高兴你问了这个问题，因为这是整个感知人类过程中非常重要的一部分。答案是：实际上很大一部分都是偏见。很多这种偏见来自于基于我们自身特殊经历的模式，包括我们观察到的事情，其中很大一部分来自于其他人告诉我们的事情。我们就像海绵一样吸收关于其他人的信息，这些方式导致我们评估某人对我们是否安全。因此，在心理学中，
lots of researchers have observed that there's a negativity bias. So we tend to hold on to negative information much more than we do positive information. And so in the case of the study that you just mentioned, we found that it was actually both white and black people who overestimated the size of black men. And one of the reasons that it's important that it applied in both cases,
许多研究人员观察到存在一种消极偏误。因此，我们倾向于记住消极信息，而不是积极信息。因此，在你刚才提到的那项研究中，我们发现实际上无论是白人还是黑人，都高估了黑人男性的体型。其中一个原因，它在两种情况下都适用的重要性在于，
is that it underscores the fact that this is really something that we are learning from each other in large part, right? That it corresponds to narratives that we tell in society that black men are stronger, bigger, more threatening, all of these things that we see bear out in these misperceptions of individuals. And so you might be familiar with a very old study from the field in which children who came from less socioeconomically privileged backgrounds, they would perceive the size of a coin as being larger than it actually was because it meant
它强调了这样一个事实，即这确实在很大程度上是我们互相学习的东西，对吧？它对应于我们在社会中讲述的叙事，即黑人男性更强壮、更大、更具威胁性，所有这些我们看到在对个人的这些错误感知中得到证实的事情。所以你可能熟悉该领域的一项非常古老的研究，其中出身社会经济特权较低背景的儿童，会将硬币的尺寸感知得比实际更大，因为这对他（她）们来说意味着
more to them. And we see that same kind of misperception happening with people as well. And that's part of what we found in this work here in particular. So in that study, although both black and white people, misperceived the size of black men.
更多的价值。我们在人们身上也看到了同样类型的错误感知。这也是我们在具体的这项研究中发现的一部分。所以在那个研究中，尽管白人和黑人都错误地感知了黑人男性的体型。
They saw them as bigger, both in height, and they saw them as stronger. They saw them as as I mentioned, taller, heavier, all of these things, it was only the white people who misperceived them as being more threatening, who converted that into believing that they were going to be more of a threat to them, they could harm them more, and thus they believed that greater use of force should be applied to keeping them from harming them.
他们认为他们更大，无论是在身高上，还是在强壮程度上。他们认为他们——正如我所提到的——更高、更重，所有这些，但只有白人才错误地认为他们更有威胁性，才将其转化为相信他们会对他们构成更大的威胁，他们会带来更多的伤害，因此他们认为应该使用更大的武力来阻止他们伤害自己。
And so that's a critical piece there that, again, intersects with that point that I made, about our subjective experiences, our idiosyncratic experiences. And so it's, again, a combination of these different streams of information coming together and informing the way that we approach each other. And so when we talk about accuracy and person perception, we think of accuracy and bias
因此，这是一个至关重要的部分，它再次与我之前提出的关于我们的主观经历、我们的特殊经历的观点相交织。因此，它再次是这些不同信息流汇聚在一起并影响我们彼此接近方式的结合。因此，当我们谈论准确性和人物感知时，我们认为准确性和偏见
just two sides of the same coin in a way. There are parts of the things that we perceive about each other that are, they're completely based on steroids. And then there are elements sometimes of those stereotypes that have kernels of truth from which they grew and overgrew. And that's one thing that we call an overgeneralization effect. And so it's those overgeneralization effects that can range from things like misperceiving the size of black men, which has some pretty serious consequences to misperceiving that someone whose face looks like a cat is going to have the attributes of a lion. And so it really does range, but it sort of speaks to this more general process that our minds use for understanding sort of who the people are around us.
在某种程度上只是硬币的两面。我们对彼此感知的某些部分，完全是基于刻板印象。有时这些刻板印象中包含着它们生长并过度生长的真相核心。这是我们称之为过度泛化效应的一点。因此，正是这些过度泛化效应，可以从诸如错误感知黑人男性的体型（这会产生相当严重的后果）到错误感知长着一张猫脸的人会具有狮子的属性。因此，它的范围确实很广，但它说明了我们大脑用来理解周围人是谁的这种更普遍的过程。
And so it's really, you know, as a scholar of this area, it's really, it can be both disheartening and also amusing at the same time, depending on what we're looking at. Well, continuing on the topic of stereotypes and bias, I want to ask you, about the question of Gaydar, the ability of some people just to judge right away, who's gay and who's straight? Is that a real thing? And are some people better at it than others? What do we know about this?
所以这真的，作为一个该领域的学者，这确实，根据我们所看到的情况，既令人沮丧又同时很有趣。好吧，继续刻板印象和偏见这个话题，我想问你关于“Gaydar”（同性恋雷达）的问题，即某些人能够一眼看出谁是同性恋、谁是异性恋的能力？那是真实存在的吗？有些人在这方面比其他人做得更好吗？我们对此了解多少？
We know a tremendous amount about it, actually, which is maybe almost embarrassing to admit. But we've, particularly in my lab, and in some others, we've done a lot of research into this. And part of it is, again, getting back to that notion that it's so unbelievable that you really sort of, once you start to find something, you really have to sort of go down the hole figuring out,
实际上，我们对此了解得惊人地多，说出来甚至可能有点尴尬。但是我们，特别是在我的实验室和其他一些实验室里，对此进行了大量的研究。部分原因，再次回到那种难以置信的观念，一旦你开始发现一些东西，你真的不得不深入钻研去弄清楚，
well, what's going on? And so people can tell whether someone is gay or straight, and more often than not, I should say. Again, there are always exceptions, and some people who seem very much like they would be gay end up being straight. And some people who seem very much like they ought to be straight, you find that they happen to be gay.
究竟发生了什么？因此，人们能看出某人是同性恋还是异性恋，而且往往如此，我应该这么说。同样，总会有例外，有些看起来非常像同性恋的人结果却是异性恋。而有些看起来非常像异性恋的人，你会发现他们恰好是同性恋。
but on the whole accuracy is not bad. It's around 60%. And that's based on really limited information, as I mentioned before. So things like just a pair of eyes in a black and white photograph, or even showing someone a picture of a person's face for one 20th of a second. So there's a lot of information there that leads people to make these judgments. And we've sliced and diced it pretty much any way that you can. And generally what we find is that it tends to be constructed on top of gender. And so women who seem, for whatever reason, whether it's the way they look, the way they sound, a combination of those, the way they walk, if they seem more masculine, then people are more
但总体而言，准确率还不错。大约是60%。正如我之前所说，这是基于非常有限的信息。比如黑白照片中的一双眼睛，甚至向某人展示一张人脸照片二十分之一秒。因此，那里有大量的信息引导人们做出这些判断。我们几乎以你能想到的任何方式对其进行了剖析和研究。我们通常发现的是，它往往构建在性别之上。因此，无论出于何种原因，无论是他们的外表、声音、这些因素的结合，还是他们的走路方式，如果女性看起来更具男性化，那么人们就会更
likely to think that they are going to be a lesbian, and chances are more often than not they are. Likewise, for men who seem more feminine, they might have a more feminine voice, they might have a more feminine way of moving their bodies. They might have more feminine features in their face. People are more likely to think that they're gay and chances are more often than not that they are. So as I said, we know a lot about gait. Are you asked if some people are better than others and we do find that there is variability in that. So generally, people who themselves are gay or straight do tend to do better. And we think that this is mostly in part just because of their amount of
倾向于认为她们是同性恋，而且往往十有八九她们确实是。同样，对于看起来更女性化的男性，他们可能会有更女性化的声音，可能会有更女性化的身体移动方式。他们的面部特征可能更女性化。人们更有可能认为他们是同性恋，而且十有八九他们确实是。正如我所说，我们对Gait（步态）了解很多。你问是否有些人比其他人更好，我们确实发现这其中存在差异。因此，通常情况下，本身是同性恋或异性恋的人往往做得更好。我们认为这主要部分只是因为他们
exposure to other gay and straight people. It's not necessarily some kind of special ability that's born into people where they can tell, but rather that we pay much more attention to the people who are like us and the people who are not. And in doing so, we learn a lot more of those subtle cues. And also, as I mentioned at the outset, there's a motivation around mating that drives a lot of our perception. So gay men are very interested in understanding what men might be available to mate with them for a couple of reasons. One is that they want to mate with those people, and the other is that if they make a mistake,
接触其他同性恋和异性恋者的数量。这不一定是因为天生具备某种能够分辨的特殊能力，而是因为我们对和我们相似的人以及不相似的人给予了更多的关注。在此过程中，我们了解了更多这些微妙的线索。而且，正如我在开篇时提到的，存在一种围绕交配的动机，它驱动了我们的许多感知。因此，男同性恋者非常渴望了解哪些男性可能愿意与他们交配，原因有二。一是他们想与这些人交配，二是如果他们犯了错，
the consequences can be very devastating for them on a personal level. And this applies to lesbian women as well. We've done some studies looking at bisexual people. That's often a question that's asked because, of course, there's more than just the gay straight dichotomy. And what we find is that people can also detect whether someone is bisexual from photos of their faces and other cues.
在个人层面上，后果对他们来说可能是毁灭性的。这同样适用于女同性恋。我们做了一些关于双性恋者的研究。这通常是一个经常被提出的问题，因为当然，除了同性恋与异性恋的二分法之外，还有更多。我们发现，人们还可以从他们面部的照片和其他线索中检测出某人是否是双性恋。
And what we generally find is that it's people who tend to seem more on the side of being gay who are sort of attributed as being bisexual and such that the dichotomy isn't so much gay versus straight. It's more like non-straight versus straight. And so anyone who's outside of sort of strict heteronormative parameters generally tends to be ascribed a non-heterosexual identity, whether that's gay or bisexual, people don't make a lot of differentiation between the two. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about how we judge people's trustworthiness or untrustworthiness and the real world consequences those judgments can have.
我们通常发现的是，那些往往更倾向于同性恋的人被归类为双性恋，以至于这种二分法与其说是同性恋与异性恋，不如说更像是“非异性恋”与“异性恋”。因此，任何超出严格异性恋规范参数的人通常往往被赋予非异性恋身份，无论是同性恋还是双性恋，人们在这两者之间并没有做出太多的区分。我们将进行短暂的休息。当我们回来时，我们将讨论我们如何判断人们的可信度或不可信度，以及这些判断可能带来的现实后果。
Wishing you could be there live for the big game, soaking up the atmosphere in a crowd. But too often, life gets busy or the price hold you back. Price line is here to help you make it happen. With millions of deals on flights, hotels, and rental cars, you can go see the game live. Don't just dream about the trip. Book it with Priceline. Download the Priceline app or visit Priceline.com.
希望你能亲临现场观看大战，沉浸在人群的氛围中。但通常情况下，生活繁忙或高昂的价格阻碍了你。Priceline来帮您实现愿望。凭借数百万张机票、酒店和租车优惠，您可以亲临现场观看比赛。不要只是梦想着这次旅行。通过Priceline预订。下载Priceline应用程序或访问Priceline.com。
Actual prices may vary, limited time offer. You thought this was your run club era. Turns out, it was more of a thinking about run club era. The good news? Someone's marathon training is about to start. Sell your workout gear on D-pop. Just snap a few. few photos and we'll take care of the rest. They get their race day fit and you get a payout for trying.
实际价格可能会有所不同，限时优惠。你以为这是你的跑步俱乐部时代。结果，这更像是“考虑加入跑步俱乐部”的时代。好消息？某人的马拉松训练即将开始。在Depop上出售你的运动装备。只需拍几张照片，剩下的交给我们。他们找到了比赛日的装备，而你因尝试而获得报酬。
Someone on Deepop wants what you've got. Start selling now. Deepop where taste recognizes taste. What are some of the other real world consequences of these kinds of judgments? For instance, you've looked at how people's impressions of a person's trustworthiness just by looking at their face, might affect criminal sentencing decisions. Can you talk about that research as well? Yeah, that's some of the most important research that I think we've done, in part because the consequences are so severe. In that work, it wasn't even only that they got harsher sentences that they actually got the death penalty. And what we found was that people who looked untrustworthy were more likely to have been assigned the death penalty by a judge and a jury.
Depop上有人想要你拥有的东西。立即开始销售。Depop，品味识别品味的地方。这些判断的其他现实后果有哪些？例如，你曾研究过人们仅仅通过观察一个人的脸来对该人可信度的印象，如何可能影响刑事量刑决定。你能谈谈那项研究吗？是的，我认为这是我们做过的最重要的研究之一，部分原因是后果太严重了。在那项工作中，甚至不仅仅是他们得到了更严厉的判决，而是他们实际上被判处了死刑。我们发现的是，看起来不可信的人更有可能被法官和陪审团判处死刑，
than people who looked more trustworthy, even in cases in which we were able to go back and find that the individual had been exonerated of their crimes. And so it's a general bias if we ask participants in the lab to simulate if they were a member of a jury, which they very well could be, because of course juries are taken from the general population, ask them, if you, this person had committed a crime,
比那些看起来更可信的人要多，甚至在我们能够回过头来发现该个人已被证明无罪的情况下也是如此。因此，如果我们在实验室里要求参与者模拟他们是否是陪审团成员——这完全有可能，因为陪审团当然是从普通大众中选出来的——并问他们：“如果这个人犯了罪，
what kind of sentence do you think they should get? they're much more likely to harshly punish to the extent of the death penalty, someone who has a face that just looks untrustworthy versus someone who looks a bit more trustworthy. Of course, the other side of that is that we tend to make mistakes around people who look especially trustworthy. And so Bernie Madoff is a good example. He has a fairly trustworthy-looking face. And so it's not a big surprise that he was able to fool a lot of people into investing with him. They trusted him. And these types of individuals,
你认为他们应该得到什么样的判决？”他们更有可能严厉惩罚那些长着一张看起来不可信的脸的人，达到死刑的程度，而对那些看起来更可信一点的人则不会那么严厉。当然，硬币的另一面是，我们倾向于对那些看起来特别可信的人犯错。伯尼·麦道夫就是一个很好的例子。他有一张相当值得信赖的脸。因此，他能够愚弄许多人与他一起投资也就不足为奇了。他们信任他。而这类人，
these sort of confidence men, as they're often called, con men, often are able to leverage their physical appearance and charisma to lure people in in ways such as that. And it's interesting, thinking about trustworthy in contrast to judgments of sexual orientation or gaydar is an important distinction because people tend to think that they're really good at judging trustworthiness. They think I can tell whether someone is trustworthy. I know whether to trust them, and they have a lot of confidence about that judgment,
这些通常被称为骗子的人，往往能够利用他们的外表和个人魅力来吸引人们陷入其中。有趣的是，将可信度与对性氧化向（性取向）或“同性恋雷达”的判断进行对比是一个重要的区别，因为人们往往认为自己非常擅长判断可信度。他们认为我能看出谁是值得信赖的。我知道是否该信任他们，他们对这种判断非常有信心，
and people feel that they cannot tell whether someone is gay or straight from looking at them. And yet, what we find is that accuracy runs in the inverse of those. People are much better than they expect at judging sexual orientation and much worse than they expect at judging trustworthiness. judgments of trustworthiness, deception, they tend to be basically chance guessing for the most part. But it's that belief that is so uncorrelated or disconnected from the reality of what they're actually able to do that fascinates people like me and the people I work with.
而人们觉得从外表看不出某人是同性恋还是异性恋。然而，我们发现准确率与这些正好相反。人们在判断性取向方面的表现比他们预期的要好得多，而在判断可信度方面的表现则比他们预期的要差得多。对可信度、欺骗的判断，往往基本上就是瞎猜。但正是这种与他们实际能够做到的现实不相关或脱节的信念，让像我和我共事的人着迷。
How hard is it to change a first impression? So as you get to know someone better, does the first impression stick or does it change as you get more information? it's extremely hard to change a first impression, I'm sorry to say. And a variety of researchers have looked at this question in a number of ways. And it is possible. It is possible to change a first impression.
改变第一印象有多难？因此，随着你对某人有更深入的了解，第一印象会根深蒂固，还是会随着你获得更多信息而改变？我很遗憾地告诉你，改变第一印象极其困难。各种研究人员以多种方式研究过这个问题。这是可能的。改变第一印象是可能的。
But what we've observed in my lab is that especially with those very quick judgments, they seem to occur persistently. And so, for example, if you were to meet somebody and you have a particular impression of them. I can take you, I can train you, and I can make you think the opposite over and over and over until you get it absolutely perfect. And then a few minutes later, you revert right back to that first impression again. And so what we've hypothesized is that this likely occurs every time you see someone, even people that you know. In those first few milliseconds, you still judge them as if there's someone that you've never seen before,
但在我的实验室里我们观察到的是，特别是在那些非常迅速的判断中，它们似乎持续存在。例如，如果你遇到了某人，并且对他们有了特定的印象。我可以带你，我可以训练你，我可以让你反反复复地反向思考，直到你绝对完美地掌握它。然后几分钟后，你又会重新回到那个第一印象。因此，我们假设这可能在你每次看到某人时都会发生，甚至是你认识的人。在最初的几毫秒里，你仍然会判断他们，就像他们是你从未见过的人一样，
almost something that you've never seen before and you make those same assessments, is this person dangerous? Can I mate with this person, so on and so forth? But what happens within a few hundred milliseconds is that you recognize the person and you overwrite that. You're then able to say,
几乎就像你从未见过的事物一样，你做出同样的评估：这个人危险吗？我可以和这个人交配吗，等等。但在几百毫秒内发生的事情是，你认出了这个人并覆盖了这一点。然后你能够说：
oh no, that's Kim, I know Kim, I feel good about Kim, I have these experiences with Kim, and so I'm not going to be scared of her anymore, and then that goes away. but it underscores again that sort of that stubbornness around these first impressions that can be quite discouraging. I could go on with lots of anecdotes about this, but I think we've all sort of had that experience at one time or another where there's someone we know and we think they don't look consistent with who they are at all. And I know them.
哦，不，那是金，我认识金，我对金感觉很好，我有这些与金相处的经历，所以我不再害怕她了，然后那种感觉就消失了。但这再次强调了围绕这些第一印象的顽固性，这可能会相当令人沮丧。关于这一点，我可以讲很多轶事，但我认为我们都曾有过这样的经历：有时我们会遇到某个我们认识的人，并认为他们看起来根本不符合他们本来的样子。而我是了解他们的。
But chances are that when you first see them every time you see them, you're thinking the same thing that everybody else is. kind of explains why you might stick with somebody as a partner who really is kind of a jerk, but you're so attracted that you can't stop, you can't change the way your brain is working. Yeah, attractiveness is one of the most powerful forces in human nature. It's true. Let's switch for a minute and talk about the role of artificial intelligence. As facial recognition and AI become more powerful and really embedded in our lives, what's going to happen as machines start making the same kinds of digital? judgments that humans make, is there a danger in that?
但很有可能，当你每次第一次看到他们时，你脑子里想的都和别人一样。这在某种程度上解释了为什么你会和一个真正有点混蛋的伴侣在一起，但你又是如此被吸引以至于无法停下来，你无法改变大脑工作的方式。是的，吸引力是人类自然中最强大的力量之一。确实如此。让我们换个话题，谈谈人工智能的作用。随着面部识别和人工智能变得越来越强大并真正融入我们的生活，当机器开始做出与人类相同的数字判断时，会发生什么？这其中有危险吗？
I think there certainly is a danger, but I'll tell you, I'm much more worried about human bias than I am about AI bias. And partly for the reason that we just discussed, right? I mean, what we've observed over, you know, many decades now of human perception is that we have a lot of confidence in stating things based on our subjective experiences that can lead us to a lot of trouble. Whether we carry this over to artificial intelligence, it looks like we probably are doing that and we'll continue to do that. As long as AI aspires to be like a human, it's going to reflect all the good and bad of what it means to be a human.
我认为肯定有危险，但我告诉你，我更担心的是人类的偏见，而不是人工智能的偏见。部分原因正是我们刚才讨论的，对吧？我的意思是，我们在人类感知方面经过了（你知道的）许多十年的观察发现，我们对根据主观经验所说的事情充满信心，这可能会给我们带来很多麻烦。无论我们是否将这一点带入人工智能，看起来我们很可能正在这样做并且将继续这样做。只要人工智能渴望像人一样，它就将反映出为人的一切优缺点。
I think there's a particular risk in people perhaps having a sense of objectivity about AI because it seems as if it ought not have bias because it's a machine. Of course, I think that that impression, I know I can speak for myself, is quickly fading. My own experiences with artificial intelligence have led me to not trust it very much at all. And so whether I'll eventually come around to trusting AI the way that I might have previously trusted a machine, that would take a lot of effort by our friends in Silicon Valley. But as I said, the more that AI emulates humans, I think that our trust in AI will continue to follow that same trajectory whereby we'll be able to discern what's trustworthy and what's not. And so, as I said, I worry a little bit about
我认为人们对人工智能可能带有一种客观性的感觉存在着特殊的风险，因为它似乎不应该有偏见，因为它是机器。当然，我认为这种印象——我知道我可以代表我自己——正在迅速消退。我自己与人工智能打交道的经历让我根本不怎么信任它。因此，我最终是否会像以前信任机器那样去信任人工智能，这需要我们在硅谷的朋友们付出巨大的努力。但正如我所说，人工智能越是模仿人类，我认为我们对人工智能的信任将继续遵循同样的轨迹，从而使我们能够辨别什么可信，什么不可信。所以，正如我所说，我有点担心
state actors and entities that have a lot of power relying on artificial intelligence to, as a tool where they haven't necessarily considered the effects of it or its own biases. But that's really no different than, again, based on my experience with artificial intelligence thus far, if they were to take a group of school children and ask them to make these important decisions. Because I would say my experience with large language models
拥有强大权力的国家行为者和实体依赖人工智能作为一种工具，而他们却没有necessarily（必然地）考虑到其影响或其自身的偏见。但根据我到目前为止与人工智能打交道的经验，这实际上与他们带上一群小学生让他们做出这些重要决定没有什么不同。因为我要说的是，我与大型语言模型的经验
has been essentially that they're very much like children telling me what they think I want to hear for the most part. none of us would responsibly, you know, pick individuals out of an elementary school to make these important decisions about, you know, profiling individuals. Yet perhaps that may be what we're doing at this moment. So I think we'll need to come a long way. But as I said, between now and then, I'm really worried about the human biases more than the computer biases. I have a work colleague who likens AI to having a not very bright intern working for you. So how should people think about this research when they're considering the impression that they're making on other people? Are there things that we should do to make a good first impression, say, on a job interview or on a date?
基本上就是它们非常像小孩子，大部分时间都在告诉我它们认为我想听的话。没有人会负责任地从小学里挑选个人来对（你知道的）关于“对个人进行侧写”做出这些重要决定。然而，或许这正是我们此刻正在做的事情。因此，我认为我们还有很长的路要走。但正如我所说，在那之前，我真正担心的是人类的偏见，而不是计算机的偏见。我有一位工作同事将人工智能比作一个不太聪明的实习生为你工作。那么，当人们考虑自己给别人留下的印象时，应该如何看待这项研究？我们在求职面试或约会时，有没有什么事情是应该做来留下良好的第一印象的？
My advice when I'm asked questions of this type is that you shouldn't think about it. Don't think about it. And I'll tell you why. You know, automatic human cognitions are not that different from, doing any other kind of complicated sequence of steps. And so if you were to, I mean, these days, there aren't a lot of, you know, automobiles with stick shift ignitions.
当我被问到这类问题时，我的建议是：你根本不应该去想它。别去想它。我来告诉你为什么。你知道，自动人类认知与进行任何其他类型的复杂步骤序列没有什么不同。因此，如果我们要——我的意思是，现在没有很多手动挡汽车了。
But if you can cast your mind back to the days when that was far more common, if you, we've all had this experience of trying to drive a car when we're not familiar with that. And it's like you've got one foot on the clutch and you've got your hand moving and you end up stalling out in traffic. The same thing is going to happen if you overthink it. The best thing that you could do, the best advice I have is don't think about the impression
但如果你能回想起那种情况更普遍的日子，如果你——我们都有过这种经历：当我们不熟悉时尝试开一辆车。这就像你一只脚踩着离合器，手在动，结果你在交通中熄火了。如果你想得太多，同样的事情也会发生。你能做的最好的事情，我得到的最好建议是，不要去想你留下的印象。
you're making. Just go and be yourself and hope that you've been lucky enough to have the right face, voice, and manner that will line up with the job that you're trying to get or the person you're trying to impress. Because ultimately, if you overthink it, you're just going to, you're just going to follow a little bit on your face. How did you get interested in studying first impression? and snap judgments.
只需去做好你自己，并希望你足够幸运，拥有能够符合你试图得到的工作或你试图打动的人的面孔、声音和举止。因为归根结底，如果你想得太多，你只会——你只会有点把事情搞砸。你是如何对研究第一印象和瞬间判断产生兴趣的？
When I was growing up, I was befuddled by things that I would see people do that contrasted with the things that they would say. And I grew up in an environment that was quite violent. There was a lot of crime. I grew up across the street from what we would have called a crack house at the time. They were not only dealing drugs, they were running prostitution and all of these things. And the altercations that would occur at a place like this would often spill over onto our property as well.
在我成长过程中，我被人们所做的事情与他们所说的话形成对比的现象搞糊涂了。我在一个相当暴力的环境中长大。那里有很多犯罪。我在当时我们称之为“瘾君子屋”的街对面长大。他们不仅在贩毒，还在经营卖淫以及所有这些事情。这种地方发生的冲突往往也会蔓延到我们的财产上。
And so I needed to develop a high level of vigilance. And in those circumstances, I started to glean pretty quickly that the judgments that people would make based on very small amounts of information were guiding a lot of the things that they would do somewhat instinctively, habitually, and seemingly without a lot of depth of
因此，我需要培养高度的警惕性。在这种情况下，我开始很快地领会到，人们根据极少量信息做出的判断，在很大程度上指导了他们的许多行为——带有某种本能的、习惯性的，并且似乎缺乏很多深度的行为。
thought. And so based on that experience, I was extremely interested in understanding that dichotomy between, as I said, what people say and what they do. And so when I had the great privilege and opportunity of going away for a post-secondary education to college, I really wanted to study this as long as I could. I was the first person in my family to go away, to get an education and I didn't think I was going to be there very long. I expected that I would fail. And so I was I was really doggedly pursuing this right from the beginning because I figured I didn't have a great window of opportunity to get an answer to these questions. And so I started asking the questions, finding answers, going to the library, irritating my professors with lots
想法。所以基于那段经历，我非常渴望去理解这种二分法，正如我所说，人们说的和他们做的是两回事。因此，当我获得去大学接受高等教育的巨大特权和机会时，我真的很想尽可能长时间地研究它。我是家族中第一个离开家去求学的人，我当时并不认为自己能在那里呆多久。我预料自己会失败。所以从一开始我就一直在执着地追求这个方向，因为我觉得自己没有多少好机会来得到这些问题的答案。于是我开始提问、寻找答案、去图书馆、用大量问题去打扰我的教授们
of questions and professors at other universities as well. At one time, my first few weeks as a freshman in college, I wrote an email to Noam Chomsky asking him a question. He wrote back with a kind reply that, you know, in retrospect, I can see he was really humoring me. But I really wanted to pursue it, as I said, as long as I could. And even once I did manage to graduate and get into graduate school, I had that same mentality where I was just going to study this for as long as I could
还有其他大学的教授。有一次，在我上大学新生的前几周，我给诺姆·乔姆斯基写了一电子邮件向他提问。他回了一封亲切的信，你知道，现在回想起来，我能看出他当时其实是在迁就我。但我真的很想继续追求它，正如我所说，只要我能坚持多久就多久。甚至在我成功毕业并进入研究生院之后，我还是那种心态，只要能研究多久就研究多久
to understand better. And so that was really the genesis of my interest in this work. And I can say how fortunate I am that I've been able to make a career out of answering a question that is meant so much to me, not just intellectually but personally as well. So looking ahead, what are the big questions that you still want to answer? What are some of the things you're working on right now? I'm really interested in understanding what it is that we don't know about ourselves. right? So again, these contradictions or, you know, hypocrisies you could even call them in people's behaviors, there's all this information that we have. You know, in studies in my lab and others have
以便更好地理解。所以这真的是我对这项工作产生兴趣的起源。我可以毫不夸张地说，我是多么幸运，能够以解答一个对我有着如此重大意义的问题为职业，这不仅在学术上，在个人层面上也是如此。那么展望未来，你仍然想解答的重大问题是什么？你现在正在研究的一些事情是什么？我非常想了解我们对自己究竟有哪些是不了解的，对吧？所以再次回到这些矛盾，或者说你甚至可以称之为人们行为中的虚伪，我们拥有所有这些信息。你知道，在我的实验室和其他人的研究中
uncovered, you know, in our perception of other people, we're taking in this huge volume of information. Our minds are unconsciously processing the majority of it, and a very small sliver seems to get promoted up to our conscious thought. And that conscious thought is sometimes misdirected, as we talked about with bias. It can lead us down paths that we wouldn't ideally like to take. And so the big question that I am still pursuing is kind of that one that I started with, which is what, what is it that we know versus we don't know? How do we reconcile those two things? Why do we say things that are different from what we do? And making sense of all of that, particularly as it applies to our perceptions of each other. Right now, one of the directions that my lab is taking with this,
我们发现，在对其他人的感知中，我们正在吸收巨大体量的信息。我们的大脑在无意识地处理其中的大部分，而只有极小的一部分似乎能够上升到我们的意识思维中。而这种意识思维有时会被误导，就像我们之前讨论过的偏见一样。它可能会把我们引向我们本不愿选择的道路。因此，我仍在追求的重大问题依然是我最初开始时的那个，那就是：我们所知道的和我们所不知道的之间究竟是什么关系？我们如何调和这两者？为什么我们说的话和做的事会不一样？并理解所有这一切，特别是当它应用在我们对彼此的感知上时。目前，我的实验室正在朝着这个方向发展，
and an area in which I'm extremely excited is thinking about the ways in which our perceptions of people extend beyond their bodies and their faces and the things that we are all actively doing in any moment, and rather the way they get sort of translated or transmuted, perhaps more appropriately, into the things with which we interact. And so there's been some work that was done
并且让我感到极其兴奋的一个领域是，开始思考我们对人的感知是如何超越他们的身体、面部以及我们在任何时刻所积极从事的事情的，而是去思考它们是如何被转化或更准确地说是演变成我们与之互动的事物的。因此，有一些研究已经开展
starting in the early 2000s on a concept called behavioral residue, And that's the idea that we leave traces of ourselves behind in places that we've been. And so, for example, there was work showing that if you go into someone's office or their bedroom, you can judge their personality traits based on a variety of things. What we're finding recently in my lab and some unpublished work that we're sending out soon for publication, is that people also embed qualities of their social categories, So the groups to which they belong, for example, whether they're a man or a woman, in things that they make.
始于2000年代初，关于一个叫做“行为残留”的概念，这个概念的意思是，我们在去过的地方会留下自己的痕迹。例如，有研究表明，如果你走进某人的办公室或卧室，你可以根据各种事物来判断他们的性格特质。我们实验室最近在一些未发表的研究中发现，这些研究很快就会送审发表，人们还会将自己所属的社会类别的特质，比如他们所属的群体，例如他们是男性还是女性，内嵌在他们制造的东西中。
And so, for example, this might apply to the things that people curate, the things that they choose, but products that they develop, even including the food that they cook. And so that's really sort of, I think, the frontier for us right now, what we're calling extrapersonal features. And I'm super excited about that work going forward. Well, this is all great information. I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Roll. this was a fun conversation. It was wonderful to be here. Thanks so much, Kim.
因此，举例来说，这可能适用于人们精心策划的事物、他们选择的事物，甚至是他们开发的产品，甚至包括他们烹饪的食物。所以这对我来说确实是我们目前的某种前沿领域，我们称之为“个人身外特征”。我对这项接下来的工作感到无比兴奋。嗯，这些都是很棒的信息。罗尔博士，我要感谢你今天能来参加我们的节目。这是一次有趣的对话。非常高兴能来到这里。非常感谢你，金。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winer, Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology点com 上找到《心理学之声》往期节目。或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube，或任何你获取播客的平台上收听。如果你喜欢我们的节目，请关注我们并留下评分。如果你对未来的节目有任何评论或想法，可以发邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学之声》由李·维纳制作，感谢收听美国心理学会节目。我是金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。